good evening Chris the organization for
the prohibition of chemical weapons
announced today it hopes to have their
inspectors on the ground working in
Syria this Saturday that could interfere
with the timing of a possible military
strike if the US decides to wait for
them to arrive presuming the Syrian
regime allows them in defense secretary
Jim mattis went further than before as
to whether a chemical weapons attack had
occurred over the weekend in Syria I
believe there was a chemical attack and
we're looking for the actual evidence
the the OPCW this the organization for
the Chemical Weapons Convention we're
trying to get those inspectors in
probably within the week the ranking
Democrat on the House Armed Services
Committee told mattis he has
reservations if a US military strike
simply involves Tomahawk missiles like
the 59 fired a year ago when Syrian
President Bashar Assad last used
chemical weapons until we have a more
long-term strategy until we have some
idea where we're going in Syria in the
Middle East
it seems unwise to me to start launching
missiles the USS Donald cook is off the
coast of Syria with about 75 Tomahawk
missiles on board and more than a dozen
surface-to-air missiles the French have
deployed a frigate to the eastern
Mediterranean armed with 16 cruise
missiles and another 16 surface-to-air
missiles to protect against any hostile
warplanes or incoming missiles
the British Prime Minister has ordered
British submarines to move into position
as well to help the USS Harry s truman
departed Norfolk Virginia yesterday
accompanied by seven US warships and
should be in the eastern Mediterranean
within a week 6,500 of the finest
Americans you could ever sail with or
serve with we're trained we're ready
any mission anytime anywhere we're ready
to go there is a risk that Allied cruise
missiles could hit Russian or Iranian
forces across Syria we are not going to
engage in the civil war itself we're
trying to stop the murder of innocent
people but on a strategic level it's how
do we keep this from escalating out of
control Fox News has also learned there
are US warships in the Red Sea in
striking range of Syria as well a
Tomahawk missile strike alone may not be
enough a year ago it had no impact on
President Bashar Assad's thinking or his
use of chemical weapons